[Music]
welcome to this episode of click to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy a solution from the
google cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll showcase how to
set up an elastic search and data flow
integration via the cloud marketplace
elastic cloud now has native integration
with google cloud dataflow which
provides customers with easy and fast
data ingestion into elastic cloud
now data from bigquery pub sub and
google cloud storage can be directly
ingested to elastic via google dataflow
let's start by searching for elastic in
the marketplace
[Music]
we'll choose the solution labeled
elastic cloud
on the solution page make sure to read
through the overview
pricing
and support to learn more about the
solution
pricing for this solution is billed
monthly or annually based on your
subscription plan
you'll notice the pricing calculator
which will allow you to model your
estimated monthly cost
start by selecting a
plan we'll keep the default plan next
choose the correct billing account then
make sure to review the terms of the
contract if you approve of them agree to
the additional terms which are about
billing and complying with the licensed
agreement
finally click the subscribe button to
launch the solution
now let's move on to the next step which
is managing your subscription with
elastic you'll need to register with an
elastic account to manage the solution
sign up or log in to your elastic
account
on elastic cloud you can create your own
deployment
a deployment includes elasticsearch
kibana and other elastic stack features
allowing you to store search and analyze
your data
we'll name our deployment test deploy
and click the create deployment button
to launch the deployment
make sure to save your deployment
credentials
and when your deployment is ready click
continue
for the purposes of this tutorial we'll
work to ingest data from bigquery to
elasticsearch but please note that you
can also ingest data from google cloud
storage and pub sub
we'll go back to google cloud
marketplace and type in stack overflow
[Music]
we'll start by ingesting the popular
stack overflow data set we'll use a
table called stack overflow posts
under the bigquery data set stack
overflow
it has several structured fields as
columns like post body title common
count etc which will bring into
elasticsearch to perform free text
search and aggregation
next step is to create a dataflow job
from a template
visit dataflow and then go to jobs
choose create a job from the template
choose name stack overflow load 1
and keep the default endpoint
choose the data flow template bigquery
to elasticsearch
[Music]
the bigquery to elasticsearch template
is one of google's provided templates
now fill in the required parameters
including your cloud id and base64
encoded api key
for the elastic search index field pick
an index name where your data will be
loaded
we'll use the stack posts index
choose a table in bigquery to read from
we'll use bigquery public data stack
overflow stack overflow posts
finally set your max workers to one
click run jobs to start the batch
processing
[Music]
when you visit kibana
within a few minutes you can see the
data flowing into your elastic search
index
and there you have it bigquery data
ingested into elasticsearch with the
click of a button
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the gcp
marketplace and deploy the solution on
your own thanks for watching
you